[Music]
what's up guys
bang bang the quality sucks today planet
keeps yelling at me but the quality
sucks welcome to lunch money well while
she's trying to get rich wrestlers just
trying to get our lunch money right get
that trillionaire energy ready bitcoin
is back 40k
ain't no bear market stop listening to
these fools
don't forget that lunch money's not
sponsored by block five planet has their
sailor outfit on
i got my black uniform on my lady here
we're ready to rock and roll block five
is now the sponsor of lunch money which
means you should go get a blockfy
account
you can earn up to eight point six
percent epy in that interest bearing
account go to blockfy.com
pomp literally go get an account if you
don't have a blackfy account at this
point
you're just missing out you're just
missing out that's it go get a blockfly
account
and you'll earn up to 8.6 apy interest
in that interest bearing account
go to blockfy.com pomp what's up let's
go
spacex's satellite broadband service
starlink is now being used in the uk
or tested in the uk after it was given a
license by uk
telecoms regulator ofcom starlink was
issued with an
earth station network license that's so
cool
so basically it's allowing it to sell
satellite dishes and other
communications equipment in the uk
so people can pick up signals emitted by
starlink's network of satellites
so the the the whole idea is like the
the satellites can like
laser on wi-fi everywhere
you tell me there's not aliens but they
got earth station network licenses
i'm just saying but listen starlink is
probably going to be one of
the most valuable pieces of technology
not necessarily from market
cap but in terms of it literally uh has
the potential to create a new network of
communication
around the earth from space and
shoot stuff everywhere information all
over
the earth google announced google
google announced that it's finally
completed the acquisition of fitbit
which was first announced in november of
2019 god it took him long enough
uh the deal had been subject to a
months-long probe into whether it could
further
further push google's market position in
the online advertising business
if it uses fitbit data to help
personalize ads
what do we think google's gonna do with
fitbit is it gonna compete with
apple fitness just get an apple watch
okay don't be selling [ __ ] i'm not
selling okay
google fitbit what is the idea look they
want data this is a great way to get
more data you can add more
personalization you can add more
uh data you can use artificial
intelligence machine learning
you can take this data as an input and
you can create better services
what if all of a sudden it says to you
they can make a recommendation now they
know on your watch that you haven't
moved that much today and they know also
that you haven't necessarily eaten that
much
and so they can say to you hey you
should take a walk and go buy a hot dog
down the street
here's the directions in google maps oh
that'd be cool actually and leave a
review on
google business now i kind of want a hot
dog
where'd you get a hot dog in miami you
don't okay
um andrew yang has entered the mayor's
race with a scaled-backed
scaled back plan try saying that 10
times fast for universal basic income
so basically andrew yang is running for
mayor's office in new york city
uh he his campaign has a pitch for
universal basic income
along with plans for high speed
broadband access smaller class sizes
and control of the city subway system
i've always said that whoever runs for
mayor on the platform
that they will
clean all the subway stations
i will vote for and and in saul ac
acs and the subway stations people that
that's your platform oh my god they
would win immediately
i'm sorry have you been in july
on the subway platform waiting for the
train you're like
i've never sweated that much in my life
i sweated
that's all you're outside basically no
you're no
you're outside and then you go down the
stairs into the inferno
and then you combust into flames okay
somebody needs to explain how science
works no yeah i know how science
i know how my sweat glands work okay
i think that andrew yang is uh
very smart he's very digitally savvy i
actually think that he's
likely to win uh if he does this
but i think universal basic income is a
horrible idea but he scaled back on
the extremes of it so it could work
it's still a horrible idea
capitalism works we simply need to
educate people so that they can benefit
from the capitalistic system
like the people who are educated and are
benefiting from it
that's all we don't need to we could
reform it a little bit
but what needs to be reformed if if you
build things of value
you capture value that's how capitalism
works
but in a world where we're gonna hand
people money for doing nothing for
breathing
it just changes the incentive system and
i think it's a really bad precedent
again there are major problems we need
to fix those problems
i'm just personally not a fan of ubi
with that said
even though i'm not a fan i still think
they're gonna do it i still think
there's gonna be mmt
i still think there's gonna be ubr like
all that stuff is coming
it's we've reached the tipping point in
society where now people are expecting
it
and i don't think you can reverse that
so i disagree with it but i can also
recognize that there's a lot of small
people who agree with it
and the probability gets implemented is
much higher
than i would like but that's just my
opinion do you remember when i
interviewed andrew yang a few months
before he ran for president
and nobody knew yes random panel
in philadelphia or something yes okay um
taco bell yawning is so weird like i
just yawned it's like where'd that come
from
i didn't tell you you need that you need
more air
no but it's just like the like like my
body is just kind of like i'm gonna yawn
now and i'm like
stop it and they're like no i'm young
maybe somebody needs to know how science
works
uh it's really biology which is a it's a
part of science
yeah just so we're saying
okay taco bell eliminated eight menu
oh she was she was whistling at me taco
bell eliminated eight manual items
incl upsetting vegetarian consumers who
likes the mexican pizza and spicy potato
soft taco
so now to appease the vegetarian
consumers
um taco bell is bringing back potatoes
and it's going to test i just like what
is that like where did that come from
why stop
i'm just saying like stop guys he gets
unreasonably upset when i start
hiccuping he's like
why are you hiccuping i'm like i can't
control me
i don't hiccup yeah you don't really
hiccup no i literally don't you know why
because i got
control but the yawning the yawning gets
past my defenses i'm like yo chill
and then it's just yawning if you are a
doctor and you understand yawning please
educate me in the comments i think it's
you need it you need it
you know i start yawning when i'm super
nervous before i have to do a big thing
i start yawning it's weird
okay so basically taco bell's bringing
back the
back the potatoes and the beyond meat
it's introducing beyond meat stuff
to appease division can i just say what
i think about this topic
are you gonna yawn no because i gotta
hurry up and talk before i start yawning
again
if you are a vegetarian why are you
going to taco bell like if you want to
be vegetarian go be vegetarian
but don't go to taco bell that's that's
stupid why not
because it's taco bell it's like oh all
of a sudden we think that one of the
worst
health decisions that we can make is
going to taco bell is not going to
become healthy that's not what their
business model is
their business model is to have really
bad food that tastes really good
and sell it really cheap that is the
taco bell business model and by the way
the shit's good so stop screwing around
with it stop trying to get them to put
fake meat in there
i'm an omnivore and i don't even go to
taco bell
okay okay so there's this man so this is
my whole thesis that people are lonely
there is this man in tokyo he's 37 years
old he rents himself out to other people
like like what is happening anthony what
are you doing the
yawn attack is real so a 37 year old
tokyo man says he rents himself out to
people to do nothing
and he's been inundated with gratitude
from twitter users
indicating people are happy with his new
form of support so basically he'll walk
around
socially distant with you on the street
um basically uh shoji morimoto has been
advertising himself as a person who can
eat and drink
and give simple feedback but do nothing
more
he's received more than 3 000 requests
and has about 270
000 followers on twitter you need to get
him on our podcast
he does nothing this guy is a savage
isn't that crazy and it's 96 dollars per
request which is 10
000 yen what a savage
i think he's giving emotional support to
people by walking
you know with them and no what he did is
he turned himself into an influencer and
now
everyone probably wants to rent so they
could take a picture with him and be
like
oh i'm with the man who does nothing
what a genius
god you would i wish i could invest in
this guy
well you should get him on the podcast
what's his name oh i missed
suji i'm gonna find you you got 270
thousand followers on twitter like
what's up hope you speak english
yeah we'll fight diva and you'll get a
translator for the podcast
no i don't need him for the podcast i
just want to be his friend okay next
okay ask lunch money time all right
so we got uh hashtag ask lm in the
comments
from kilo hey love and appreciate the
value and the content you guys put out
you guys are awesome what advice would
you give your younger self
i just fought one off by the way i'm i'm
fighting back now these y'alls are
trying to come at me and
uh uh this whole episode is trash
it's three to one yawns to me but yes i
gotta win i'm not on
i'm not fully defeated what advice would
you give your younger self for me
i wish that i believed in myself more
than other people believed in me when i
was younger because i think i sold
myself
sold myself short is that a saying yes
okay and and i was in english and i was
undervalued
but if i had believed in myself and my
own abilities i wouldn't have let
people undervalue me that is all what
about you i personally never had that
problem
i probably believed in myself too much
uh
but i would just go bigger
like just go big if you're gonna do the
work just go big
all right cool like put a zero on the
end of whatever you're doing matthew
that would have been my advice to myself
put a zero on the end let me say the
name
matthew o'brien hey team as a daily
listener of the show i'd love to hear
your thoughts on why pomp chooses to
i saw that to write a daily newsletter
whereas felina chooses to write her
newsletter weekly
so i choose mine weekly because i think
that so
all these long form profiles come out
during the week and i think
as a reader you probably have the most
time to sit down and read something
long on sundays so that's why i thought
that was a good idea why did you think a
daily was a good idea i got a lot to say
and i almost say it and i don't care if
anyone reads it
but it happens to be that a lot of
people want to read it but i'ma say what
i gotta say thank you guys we appreciate
you
if you understand yawning please leave a
comment and help me understand
i just fought one off so now i think
that like maybe i could just get up my
yawn defense i don't know how to tell
you this but people comment on every
uh video saying like pomp's yawning oh
really
yeah you yawn all the time well it's
probably because my body is rejecting
all the [ __ ] it's like
get it out see you tomorrow guys
hey kids i got a surprise for you
tomorrow see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated
but 8.6 is pretty compelling so click on
the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel
like the video annoy pulling in the
comments and we'll see you guys tomorrow
and be kind to your friends